good morning ladies and gentlemen I'm
going through the emergency evacuation
announcement should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the building by the nearest
available exit to the chamber our
assembly point will be in a public car
park at the side of the Civic suite
please do not delay your evacuation to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building unless until
given permission to do so by the council
staff please note that this meeting will
be audio recorded and can I ask if
you've got mobile phones could you put
them on silent I'll turn them off please
thank you today we're meeting to
determine the application of personal
license for mr. Oliver Owen and on my
right I have have run out sim Arthur
Williams council Arthur Williams and
councillor Otto and Rebecca Hurst
can I have the sorry about this the
requests the following persons to
identify eyes find themselves including
their representative if applicable so
the applicant please
yo mister I thank you
Stephen greener I'm the Roche accounts
all licensing officer Thank You Joanne
Stansbury County licensing officer for
Essex Police and there's no any other
responsible for any interested parties
yes
right the procedure if we fall out of
the hearing is reference three item
three of the agenda for the hearing and
can I draw your attention that we have
15 minutes and if you are speaking can I
ask you to put your mic on and be be
aware that if anyone else has got their
mic on
once you finish can you turn it off
because on the chamber they don't work
okay thank you
so I'll be an officer first please
good morning just to introduce the
application for a personal license made
under Section 1 1 1 of the licensing act
the application must be determined to
within 5 working days of the conclusion
of the hearing in accordance with
paragraph 26 of the licensing Act 2003
hearings regulations 2005 the
application was submitted to the
licensing authority by Cpl training and
refers to the applicant mr. Oliver Owen
appendix a of your package includes a
copy of the original application form
the application was dispute with its
police and immigration on the 31st of
October for consultation with a deadline
of the 14th of November 2017
um Wednesday the 8th for November 2017
the licensing authority received a
representation from Essex Police against
the application the objection notice was
served under the licensing acts 2003
section 120 paragraph 5 that the
applicant has a current unspent criminal
conviction appendix B is a copy of the
Egyptian notice issued by Essex Police
Appendix C is a copy of the home of his
documentation outlining the relevant
offenses all parties involved have been
served with the relevant notices
documentation as required by paragraph 6
& 7 of the licensing acts 2003 hearings
regulations 2005
the authorities required to take steps
to consider it consider appropriate for
the promotion of their licensing
objectives the prevention of crime
disorder Public Safety the prevention of
public nuisance and the protection of
children from harm in considering this
application members must also have
regards to the statement of licensing
policy and section 182 guidance issued
by the secretary of state the following
options are available to members to
grant the application or to reject the
application the proposal is that the
subcommittee resolves the determination
of the application having considered all
representations made at the hearing and
that's the conclusion of the report
Essex Police are objecting to the
application to grant a personal license
for Oliver Owen the objection
notice was served according to the
license in that 2003 section 120 D that
the applicant has a current unspent
relevant events in December 2017 over
Owen pleaded guilty and was convicted of
convicted at North East London
Magistrates Court of a driving motor
vehicle with excess alcohol on the 29th
of October 2014 in Rockford Essex at the
time of his arrest and conviction mr.
Wayne was a serving Metropolitan Police
Officer this raises serious concerns as
to mr. Owens ability to uphold the four
objectives of the Licensing Act in the
1974 the licensing Act was drawn up to
ensure that only persons of effect and
proper character could hold a position
of a licensee despite amendments and
changes in the license in act 2 2003
this necessity of being able to hold a
position of responsibility and adhere to
regulations and legislation is a
requirement continued in the role of
designated prime supervisor of which a
personal license holder if branded would
be able to apply for for this reason the
true weight of responsibility
encompassed in the position cannot be
ignored and placed in the hands of
police at application stage to be
assessed and cross-reference against the
license in act 2003 and any recognized
as relevant offenses is the weighty
responsibility to balance a person's
need to gain suitable employment against
the demonstration of suitable and robust
character to carry out this responsible
role due to the seriousness of the
offence and disregard for UK law and the
safety of others when already in a
position of responsibility Essex Police
opposed the granting of the personal
license until completion of
rehabilitation period
that's it
try again yes I'm Sue's my squeaky voice
I seem to be they could could you just
enlarge on the circumstances surrounding
the the the actual them drink-driving
effect the famous
you stole his license was a dost and
dost and 16 weeks essex 16 months bang
and due to the amount of alcohol found
in his urine
according to our research and after
speaking to the licensing officer at
barking mr. Owen had attended a
Christmas do and unfortunately there
just seems to be some inconsistencies on
the application form leaf and it has
here that the it was on the 20th of the
12th I'm not sure obviously 13th of the
there but on the please police objection
now to you says that mr. Ryan pleaded
guilty on the 22nd of the 12th so was it
a year or between being caught and then
pleading guilty thank you
I think I can provide a little bit more
clarity around that if they will help
the application when I originally looked
at the application form on the
handwritten seems to indicate that it
was 2017 on page 182 is so 1.8 is that
what you're referring to and then
obviously the letter from Essex police
states it was on the 22nd of December
2014 what hasn't been included in here
is a copy of the DBS certificate and I
believe it was actually 2014 that the
offense as you went to court rather than
2017 it will be five years to 2019 is
when the conviction will be spent
this is gonna step him I think counselor
rotom's question was perhaps and the
answer would stop short because of the
fact that it was a question about other
convictions which wouldn't be relevant
but I think but he was wanting to know
the circumstances of the offense the
facts of the offense I think the officer
had started to say that I don't know if
you'd like to hear yes I think
so you you want the actual explanation
of the research behind this of the event
picture would just like to know that the
facts of the the offense short summary
of the circumstances he started saying
it was after a Christmas do after
speaking to the license in officer at
barking his research showed that mr.
Owen had been to a Christmas Day
unfortunately missed his train and then
decided to drive home
he was then pulled over by fellow
officers and taken into custody he did
not give a roadside sample and after
several hours in custody then gave a
urine sample
first of all I would like to thank you
for your time and this opportunity
before going any further I just wanted
to say at no point am I trying to
justify what I did I know this was wrong
and I've learned from my mistake
I've never would would make the same
mistake again but I think I've been
punished enough I'm a very good covered
sir in January 2003 I joined the MIT
metropolitan police force I started my
career in Hackney which is one of the
most diverse boys in London I spent over
eight years in Hackney starting off from
a response team on between 900 on to the
plainclothes task force which involved
targeting suspects of violent crime in
2011 I joined sa 23 which was a
dedicated police team for the London
Olympics I led a small team working in
the Olympics athletes village and in
Olympic venues after the Olympics I
moved to one foot I was in charge of the
nighttime economy teenis involved
working closely with the licensing team
and council and license venues to ensure
they were following their licensing
conditions on a 25th of the 10th 2014
my monk bear my grandmother died she was
like your mother to me my mother and dad
divorced when I was young and my
grandmother brought me up once my walk
my mother was at work only 29th for the
10 2014 I attended a work night out I
had two ways to stay at one of my
colleagues houses but late in the
evenings my colleague had an argument
with his partner and I was aim unable to
stay at his house because it was so late
I missed my last train my phone battery
was dead and I was unable to contact my
wife to pick me up where only option
wants to sleep at the police station as
I was walking back to the police station
had a stupid for I made the biggest
mistake of my life I remembered my car
was parked in residents parking and I
decided to move my car to the next row
to avoid getting a parking ticket I was
in my car for Fox and me four to five
minutes when a police unit who I knew
very well stopped me and then I was
arrested I was in a pretty service for
11 years I had an impeccable
disciplinary records I'd received a
number of accommodations for my hard
work
never ever been in any kind of 12 or
prior to this incident I can put my hand
on my heart to say we'll never be in any
trouble again this was definitely the
worst moment of my life due to this
incident I had to resign from a job I
loved which I served the public to the
best of my ability for 11 years
I passed my sergeant's exam and Borden's
awaiting for my provoked promotion start
day not only was I devastated but my
wife left me
my mother didn't talk to me for three
months but this was my own fault I had
no one else to blame but myself I had to
move on with my life not only my wife
left me my mom was not talking to me and
I was jobless for the first time since I
was 13 years old I had to just myself
down and move on with my life after
along with Koopman process I got a new
job as a security manager for Transport
for London
I worked quickly promoted to Deputy
Account Manager and then to Account
Manager I'm now working for I suppose
casino in Stratford which is the biggest
casino in Europe I'm calling in a senior
security manager I've been working there
for three months I've just received my
first review and I'm doing very well it
clearly states and my contract I need to
gain a personal alcohol license to
remain employment if I do not obtain
this license I will be unemployed I
understand the police have objected to
my license because I have a relevant
unspent conviction and if the license
was granted it would undermine and
licenses objective of preventing crime
my argument today is that I've made a
mistake I've paid dearly for that I lost
my wife and my job I have impeccable
coverage of Records and have never been
into a wall place before this incident I
believe my private police in background
without the opposite effect
I will possibly prevent porn from my
point for our experience and we
excellent knowledge of the licensing Act
I've recently completed my licensing
course there were 25 students why scored
the highest she wanted to thank you
again for this time this opportunity
excuse me mr. Owen um did you refuse her
breath test at the side of the road at
the time of her arrest and then again at
the police station
I back on thank you thank you for
waiting the committee has given evidence
careful evidence and consideration to
the application and all of the written
and verbal evidence presented including
the objection notice from the Essex
Police we know the applicant has a
conviction dated 22nd December 2014
almost three years ago the conviction
will become spent in two years time it
is the case that the applicant could
apply for this license in two years time
and would fulfill the necessary criteria
we are aware that the authority must
object
Vasari must reject the application if it
considers it's appropriate for the
promotion of the crime prevention to do
so we heard that the police objection
related to the nature of the offence and
the fact that the applicant was so a
serving police officer at the time and
was therefore in a position of authority
however we do not feel that there is any
direct correlation between the facts of
the offence of this offense and the sale
of or supply of alcohol we have taken
into account that there are no further
relevant convictions we have heard that
a direct result as a direct result of
this single conviction the applicants
long-standing career as a police officer
ended however the applicant has
subsequently been able to obtain and
hold positions of responsibility as a
security manager for Transport for
London and in these current employment
as a security manager manager at a
casino we take the view that in this
particular case the applicant will be
more aware of his responsibilities as a
personal license holder in respect to
the sale and supply of alcohol for these
reasons we do not feel that the grant of
this person Elijah's license further
undermined their license it's an
objective of prevention of crime and
disorder and accordingly the personal
license is granted this concludes the
hearing and thank you all for attending
thank you
thank you
mojo emergency evacuation announcement
should we be required to evacuate the
building would you please leave the
building via the nearest available exit
to the change chamber our assembly point
will be in the public car park at the
side of the Civic suite please do not
delay your evacuation to collect any
belongings please please do not return
to the building until given permission
to do so by the council staff please
make sure your phones are on silent or
turned off please note this meeting will
be audio recorded thank you this
application is to determine a template
temporary event notice for the skylight
hotel struck 0 6 at South End we are
having attendance counselor on item
Williams and our senior solicitor
Rebecca hearse we haven't got any
applicant in attendance we have the
council licensing our offices Jen Fowler
principal nice it's an officer with
licensing Stephen green Oh Roger Council
licensing officer thank you and Joe
entertain three County licensing officer
for Essex Police thank you very much
there will be 15 minutes premisses for
any responsible authority to present
their submissions and we'll go to our
our DC officers please
but afternoon and this report introduces
an application for a temporary event
notice made under Section 100 of the
license in act 2003 during the
consultation period an objection was
received from the police regarding the
planned event the application must be
determined at the conclusion of the
hearing at least 24 hours before the
beginning of the event in accordance
with paragraph 26 one of the license in
act 2003 here in regulations 2005 and
section 105 4 of the license in act 2003
on the 23rd of December 17 a temporary
event notice was received from mr.
andreas 7e it is of the skylark Hotel
aviation Way southend-on-sea the notice
was for an event to be held at 0-6
suites on the 15th of December 17 from
1800 hours until 2255 hundred hours the
licensable activities are for the sale
of alcohol the provision of regulated
entertainment and the provision of
late-night refreshment the maximum
number of people attending the event is
to be 499 the hotel already holds a
premises license although this excludes
the external area and 0-6 suite an
objection notice was received from the
chief of police on the grounds that the
use of the premises in accordance with
the temporary event notice was
undermined the crime prevention and
Public Safety objectives of the Act all
parties involved have been served with
the relevant notices and documentation
required by paragraph 6 and 7 of the
license in act 2003 here in regulations
2005 the licensing authority must serve
any notice required under section 105 3
of the license in act 2003 at least 24
hours before the beginning of the event
the options for the for the committee
are to determine the event would
undermine the licensing objective of the
prevention of crime and disorder and
server cancer notice stating the reasons
for that decision or to allow the
license of elective --'tis to go ahead
as stated in the notice recommendation
it is proposed that the subcommittee
resolves to determine the issue having
considered all representation
made at the hearing
okay
Essex police ask for the temporary event
notice to be objected to on the basis of
our submission which I take that
everyone is right just to outline we
received a ten with regard to a boxing
activity it was later discovered I
believe it was Facebook which was
advertised by Charles Carter the
promoter that they were actually going
to be doing bare-knuckle fighting the
rules that they stay here is there are
going to be dog house rules one round of
unlimited minutes three knockdowns a
knockdown rule fight until someone quits
or is knocked out and doesn't beat the
count of 20 or heart sign from the
police's point of view the lack of
actual rules that this fight and the
advert envisages is conspiracy to commit
GBH I refer to our case law of Lourdes
Lane where he says that in bases that
people don't actually agree to be
publicly harmed within bare-knuckle
fighting we have had several deaths I
believe there was one in Great Yarmouth
which was quite publicized and this is
of say not regarded as boxing
there are various rules and regulations
which adhere to the boxing from the
police have not been able to actually
risk assess the event we have not been
able to confirm the door staff we have
tried to contact the door staff company
without success investigation shows that
it was a door company created by a
builder who builds in the day and does
door staff in the evening but he was not
detectable to discuss what risk
assessments he'd actually done to
control the crowd if the event continues
then we would probably have to proceed
with a closure notice which would cause
even more problems and mass public
disorder when emptying the premise the
temporary event notice does not say that
there's a bare-knuckle fight it says
it's boxing he has had previous books
and events and we have had no problems
with the boxing events but this concerns
us very much as it is bare-knuckle and
has no rules at all rather problem with
this particular event is the fact that
it will be held at zero six zero six is
not a licensed part of the premise so
therefore no conditions can be put on
and it is an unlicensed area therefore
we are asking for the temporary event
notice not to go through
got some questions I had one question
have our offices scenery risk assessment
have we seen they've not put it in with
their application for no risk assessment
at all not a fault what you'd expect or
any event in the last 24 hours I have
seen documentation that has come through
from the promoter and also from the
applicant we've details of the boxes of
their names and their dates of birth but
not a full risk assessment that you
would expect for a full event management
event such as the number of door staff
how they're going to manage the crowds
none of that has actually been received
by us no paramedics no doctors advised
there is mention of paramedics and
doctors but it just says that there will
be paramedics and doctors present there
is lack of detail within the information
that's come through what thank you very
much that's my question
it states that unlicensed event if it
were licensed event
regulated entertainment is obviously the
music and dancing of things but there is
a license for activity for boxing and
wrestling and if he's on the license so
if you did have a premises license and
he had boxing and wrestling on there
then it would be licensable but then we
would still if we knew about the event
we would ask risk assessments and again
if we saw this sort of advert it would
be flagged up
question for the police
what crime issues do you see to the
actual boxes is a conspiracy to commit
GBH and this type of event is notorious
for public disorder hence without the
door staff and risk assessment icon.this
sorry thank you very much
three the parties once just summing up
on it for two minutes said all we got so
you've got to thank you we're gonna
adjourn it for a decision and we will
come back to you thank you
oh sorry it was longer than 20 minutes
the committee has given careful
consideration to the application and all
the written and verbal evidence
presented including the objection notice
from Essex Police the committee has not
heard from the applicant or any
representative representative and we can
therefore only base our decision on the
evidence presented to us at this hearing
we have heard evidence from the place as
to the nature of event which is not
conventional licensed boxing evidence
has been provided on Facebook
advertisements promoting the event on
the 15th December 2017 and the skylark
hotel as a bare-knuckle brawl the
company and the company wording refers
to dog house rules with one round of
unlimited minutes it does not appear to
follow the rules of rec of a regulated
boxing match in addition we have heard
that a full detail risk assessment has
not been submitted and pls have not been
able to verify the security arrangements
the place of submitted case law Lord
Lane in the attorney general reference
number six of nineteen eighty stroke
1991 which states it is not in the
public interest that people should try
to cause or should cause each other
actual bodily harm and assert that an
event of this nature could amount to an
offense of conspiracy to commit grievous
bodily harm and we accept the public the
police evidence furthering furthermore
more they have also raised the increased
risk of increased public disorder at the
events of this nature we take the view
that an event with a capacity of up to
499 people with no full risk assessment
unregulated and with the supply of
alcohol does increase the risk of public
disorder and criminal offenses occurring
we also know that the venue is not part
of the licensed premises and therefore
no conditions can be attached for these
reasons the committee has determined
that to notice a counter notice should
be served in
order to rope the objective of
prevention of crime and disorder this
concludes the hip hearing